- boom what's up man how are you hello
thanks for easier well I'm pleased to
get here it's a kind of a strange day in
this part of this is strange as it ever
gets there the big concern in Los
Angeles has always been according to a
firefighter that I've talked to once
that the right wind catches a fire and
it takes it all the way through Los
Angeles down to the coast yeah it's not
quite that it didn't go through
Hollywood it didn't go they think one
day it's gonna happen and with the right
wind they're not gonna be able to stop
it but yeah this is pretty bad this is
about as bad as I've ever seen it happen
all in one day yeah it was extraordinary
on the road to get here just this huge
just this huge pillowy I thought it was
just you know mountains and I thought it
was a strange cloud formation but it was
just smoke smoke yeah it looks like a
giant gray mountain in the distance
yeah it's it's insane how bad it's
gotten I've had it happened three this
is the third time I've been evacuated
since I've moved here 20 plus years ago
yeah it gets rough but this is the
roughest I've ever seen Jamie and I were
doing the podcast yesterday and when it
was over I had like five text messages
from friends that live in my
neighborhood saying how bad it was and
then when we got home the wind was just
crazy and it's just it's just it's
humbling you know I mean it's a super
unfortunate for all the people that are
losing their homes and and losing their
you know losing their property but the
reality is this is its nature you know
this is just something that you just
can't avoid there's nothing you can do
about it gets dry like this and I don't
know what started it I hope it wasn't a
cigarette that's the big actually so
many morons to throw in cigarettes it's
not just a weather thing that just
happens it's it is literally things like
cigarettes and yeah unfortunately a lot
of the times I mean the weather
certainly accentuates it because it's
dry and windy and this is fire season
they're not bad right
amazing because they support your back
as well with a 47 year old man this is a
helpful time keep bouncing away from the
microphone which I'm sure isn't good but
yeah they're incredible they keep you
sitting straight they accentuate your
posture they do there you go so what's
up man what are you doing in town for
this back chest out yeah they would be
proud there you go
I'm here yeah I'm hitting uh I'm here
for a week I've been I've got a show on
Netflix has to come out so I'm just kind
of generally here to talk about it I
guess and seen a couple of friends and
it's been a really nice really nice week
yeah this is a good way to end it too
with a giant fire that's just a giant
fire and get the [ __ ] out it's people
are crazy living here there's no water
it never rains yeah it'll be it's very
different back home yeah it's it's it's
it's amazing just at this time of year
leaving England and coming to somewhere
like I mean I'm sure I'm sure you don't
take it for granted but you know it's it
is amazing just for the weather just do
you like did you like LA as a like as a
place and a home and a does it I mean
you've got an amazing sort of setup here
is it just is it just a dream place to
you know it's uh it's a love-hate
relationship
certainly the the real problem is the
population is just so insane there's
more than 20 million people plus who
knows people you know how many they
really don't have no idea how many
people snuck in you know it's it's just
a chaotic place there's no public
transport it just hit me there's no
trains there's no infrastructure of so
everyone's driving this huge yeah
everyone has an escalator a Tesla or
something yeah it's it's just a strange
place if there's the highways are
massive you know you know five six lanes
on each side and they're jammed solid or
nothing's moving either way and if you
can see it from there really we realize
how preposterous it is when you're
flying into LAX and you see the 405
highway in the distance and it's all
stopped for as long as you can see miles
and one-way miles the other way just
complete parking lot just realize wow
what are we doing here
the finally spot with great weather and
you know and then the entertainment
industry draws people in I don't know
maybe it's better to be in England